what's up my bros it is time for another
late horror game that's right you guys
love horror kings I know that you like
it so live so if you liked it make sure
to smash that like button right now if
we destroy it literally I'm talking
about game breaking destroying the
YouTube glitch bug
I'm literally saying if we can break the
YouTube algorithm that's right everybody
there will be another part two if that
happens this video is called try not to
fall asleep challenge I was trying to
watch the Jack play this but I just fell
asleep so I figured why don't I just
play it myself I'm just kidding oh great
is another fine ass of Freddie clone
fantastic okay why not
alright let's remain positive squid
heron right nice to meet you mr. heron
closes a bee as a medical assistant
robot my core function is to give
guidance to my patients and provide a
supportive presence okay an emergency
such as a mental breakdown okay okay
then mutant robot
good good tuck okay so I'm just gonna
chill you know we're just gonna fall
asleep together this is now an ASMR
video
hey let's fall asleep this is the sound
of my beard yeah
whoa what was that oh god I'm getting
super stressed what's happening I can't
keep the light on for too long okay this
is fine I'm really good at
micromanagement so this is totally fine
hello
why is falling asleep so stressful looks
like you got a high hallucinations too
hard it's time I don't mind sleeping
with someone stares at me makes it's
actually comforting for me makes me feel
good makes me feel nice that's normal
that's just our local alcoholic a local
drunkard oh that's who looks like you
got a big hallucination there next time
you should hide in the blanket before
that happens how do you know what I'm
hallucinating
[Music]
that's normal that's normal I don't have
any problem with any of this
oh dude that's really bad all right
surely I'm falling asleep now yeah no
but I'm asleep just thank you thank you
oh wait what all right so now I am
someone else oh exit the main lab
building and locate the power generator
man I am tall dude wow this is kind of
creepy to study on plant endurance
that's plenty of work for me
Wow game of the year everyone it's like
I'm taking ginormous steps
it's a microscope thank you game
Jesus whoa I got a little spooked down
at or nothing I'm not smelling exit
perfect let's just go to the exit hello
hello fine what are their names perfect
if yours is oh damn it alright let's
find the fuses bros easy good thing I
never a look at that random fuse oh
please I'm good I'm good
I'd rather accept my fate I said I
changed my mind
sheesh are you spooked out yet I am
literally dying it's a good thing I
never get scared while playing games
unlike you you little cry-baby
it says my stress went up a little bit
and I kinda have to agree to be honest
Oh fair one heck yeah
awesome pick it met my dude like I don't
fine
fine so at one time I had too much sugar
I got all crazy I just owe success heck
yeah guys smash that like button right
now if you thought that was the success
come on
have you ever liked or single one of my
videos well today is the day other
people watch Buddha but do you think
they're inside the building I wonder
maybe I should check real quick
hello oh there are okay oh gosh gosh I
forgot oh my gosh
[Music]
to much sugar I'm going in circle our
name
[Music]
suck shush
smash that like fun right now guys can
we smash it
hello hello fuse fuse
give me the fuse fuse
give me a fuse come out give me refuse
give me the fuse come on man I said
taste Vista they were a fan smash like
come on guys
man it feels great not to be one of
those creaky youtubers anymore like I
rent I ran here like a million times
already like dog you can't keep doing
that
come on where is it I don't have all day
they've all fee in it who just put
random fuses everywhere everywhere how
about you had stored them in the storage
and not just sprinkle them over like
glitter yeah my few spot yeah my first
fine it has to be inside I looked
everywhere outside it may be one of the
top floors oh can it can it can they can
they can they can they can they can come
in
[Music]
Oh Joe Joe Joe Joe this is bad this is
really bad guys
guys I don't have great feelings about
did it's very not good my in it hey you
know I hate okay okay hey wait does your
deviant we're fine take that pole in
[Music]
your teeth they're poor and feet that
oh that was stressful thank God
I see the parts my god did you pick what
do you think cage with the sea the
futures just scrambled all over the
place I had to go find them and put them
back yeah it was weird Kate I bet you're
the one that did it your quad yellow
weasel I'll wait for you at the entrance
lobby in the lamp okay Kate Kate all
right I think it's over here hello whoa
oh no not Kate
ain't that far what about Kate Kate Kate
oh you're right Kate are you sleeping
right now honestly Kate really
disappointed in you I just fixed all I
fixed all of the generators Kate Kate
Kate I fixed all of the generator and
here you are just sleeping sleeping
slumbering away that was the point of
the game of course they don't make sense
oh she's dead okay oh oh that was a
dream interesting I look down and my
balls are gone that's just my nightmare
okay thank you for playing the beta I
did it to everyone Bassel good job
Bassel you did it you did a game Bassel
okay that was tried to try not to fall
asleep it was interesting I've
definitely played better but I've also
definitely played worse so and this is
hourly version so who knows maybe it
will get better and more interesting
that's it for me for now
watching another episode of the final
okay see you guys in the next one
this is me goodbye to Mike the Edgar